okay on the Internet
Jon Meacham would have Jeb Bush
president Cena you just wrote the book
about his father more closely resemble
his father's or his brothers oh good
question
I think would resemble his father's more
and I really I do because I mean did
that all the three of them are different
guys
despite the genetic material and the old
I know that's the science denial I
realized but I'm trying to talk to the
base so but what's so interesting about
about his campaign is he does not have I
mean dub you could you know they at
least pretend he was really into
campaigning his father really did like
it although he didn't believe anything
he said while he ran for office
um but he liked you know he once shook
the hand of a department store mannequin
and god only knows what a Clinton would
have done with it so there's that whole
problem so I think that I think that he
but he I think he's more deliberative
and I think his father was clearly more
deliberative ultimately than his son
okay Seth MacFarlane would you ever
consider hosting the Oscars again uh Wow
it's sure why not did they not ask you
the year after you hosted they did yeah
the ratings were good yeah yeah right
yeah people cannot be cowed by the
virtual vigilantes we have to make a
stand you know you did nothing on that
show that was the least bit untoward oh
we saw your boobs was that the thing
that the feminists were so upset about
my saw your butcher saw your boobs that
was funny we cuz we do see their booth
III to me it was like you know that you
read headlines like the failure of the
Oscars it's like well the ratings were
up and the crowd was great like I've
done stand-up where it hasn't worked
that was a great crowd where are you
getting that that didn't work hey
there's just so much hate oh it's old
news it's old news all right
Michael McCaul which of the Republican
candidates are best on Homeland Security
no they're all bloodthirsty
knuckle-draggers okay it's so hard to be
back oh yeah they all wanted you know
carpet bomb Isis right right can I go to
Switzerland on this one or be agnostic
like you I yeah I just want to i want a
commander-in-chief that can stabilize
the region defeat and destroy isis and
protect the homeland I in I want a
strong leader they can do that I you
know I'm looking at you look at my book
in the recommendations to protect the
homeland whatever candidate the doves
recommendations I will support but
defeat and destroy Isis you know I mean
I know you've spoken against his patient
approach but actually Isis is quite a
bit degraded since we started bombing
and we've dropped like 28,000 bombs on
them they have lost major cities in Iraq
a lot of territory even in Syria they've
lost territory we bomb their money this
week they had to fence it yeah
who's gonna be against that they had to
cut their salaries by half and these
guys have sex slaves to feet I mean that
was none it's all right I'm here
Ida yes you learn to accept the first
it's like oh oh I'll be covered and then
I'll decide if it's funny oh yeah okay
all right but we've made some progress I
was over in Iraq last May and Ramadi
fell now we've taken Ramadi back that
that's a positive thing but when you
have you know go from 15 to 20 to 30 35
foreign fighters in the region that
that's a problem when you over the
internet have a growing ideology that's
tough we have to we have to have a
counter narrative to defeat the ideology
and a drone strike alone is not gonna
kill it no I mean that maybe we're gonna
has repeated yet we get it it can yes
it's part of what we strikes are
important but ideology is important I
can ask
yes in your view is Donald Trump
qualified to be commander in chief
mr. perfect you can only make it worse
now that through my bidet if I can take
care of it if I become his Secretary of
Homeland Security I'll be building that
big beautiful wall making lesson well
that's uh well okay yeah you've answered
no chairman thank Alan Grayson well you
know what I'm gonna ask you a different
question this is hugging your money out
of politics but you are the one who was
gonna bring the lawsuit against Ted Cruz
that Donald Trump keeps talking about
he's the nominee yeah when Donald Trump
says the devil
I'm not gonna sue him but the Democrats
will he means you he actually mentioned
me Yeah right
so because you think you think Ted Cruz
is not eligible to run for president
well he relies upon his mother to try to
establish his citizenship who's born in
Canada he says that he's a born natural
born citizen the United States because
his mother was a citizen but his mother
actually was a registered voter in
Canada but that doesn't affect her
citizenship I'm a dual citizen citizen
of two countries and I vote it did in
1970 what you should not vote more than
once
well I do you might have a problem there
where are your resident why are you
voting where you're not a resident
because I'm legally allowed to and I'm a
citizen of Surrey and I pay taxes you
can vote in a place I I think there
might be police waiting to arrest you
right after the show
it happens if there are if there are I
suspect it's for an entirely different
reason but it is the other comes like it
this is like a Ross Rachel okay you're a
British as I'm would hasten to point out
as I would hasten to point out I
actually believe Donald Trump is I'm an
English qualified lawyer and on the
basis of the way that British
nationality transmits because his mother
was Scottish and I don't believe she
ever reject I'm totally serious about
this
unless he's well no I'm totally serious
about I know you are but it's silly I
know you're serious I don't all of us
have that that's not that no one ever
thought that that was part of the
problem oh I don't think it's a problem
I'm just saying I think that it's a
little bit funny that he's like
attacking Cruz on this when he is a dual
citizen that's all I'm saying I'm fine
with it
I I'm I would you know I don't like
Trump but if we had another dual US UK
citizen would be happy to see my P his
mother was a Scottish citizen and not an
American when she became one but she you
maintain dual it's very hard to give up
British citizenship you basically have
to walk into the embassy and say I
revoke my British citizenship which he
was born in America I was not
I'm not saying Donald Trump isn't in him
right okay I'm saying they're both they
were both born with dual citizenship
that doesn't make you not American I'm
American I'm a dual citizen but if his
mother was a Canadian and not an
American then he is not a natural-born
citizen American well how do you know
that she was a registered voter in
Canada an interesting boater doesn't you
by registering to vote someplace you
don't give up your nationality she must
have been a Canadian citizen if she was
a Canadian ready allowed the United
States allows people to have dual
citizen t I hope I just wait for
moment when we discover that if it is
about your mother
no one ever doubted that Obama's mother
was American right right it's something
somehow that's switch right well that's
[ __ ] too but it's all the same
[ __ ]
well what I'm saying Trump's full of
this [ __ ] and look you want a job
that's fine but I think it's [ __ ]
crazy
well no no what's what's not crazy is to
defend the Constitution it's the
Constitution we're talking about here
the Constitution says if you're less
than 35 years old you can't be President
I'm sorry but there's a lot of people
Esther Mark Zuckerberg is less than 35
years old Cathy president george w bush
all right electric twice-baked president
you go read what was written by a team
of former solicitors general from two
different administrations two parties in
the Harvard Law Review about this and
you need to study the history a British
him all right oh okay acident all right
sorry Shirley okay I apologize okay
well all I know I'm away either you guys
are on to this if the Ted Cruz was
really Canadian could he be that much of
an asset
he is an his revenge for acid rain I
guess so did Sean Penn's interview with
El Chapo breach any journalistic ethics
well they got on his case because El
Chapo did have final say over the
article but El Chapo didn't change
anything in that article I would say in
defense of my friend Sean Penn that
that's pretty much the standard in
journalism these days is that you people
give the people that are interviewing a
veto power over it all the time anyway
because they don't want them to go away
I won't insult you Donald Trump I need
you for ratings and you have to be back
here tomorrow so I'm not gonna ask a
follow-up question well where do you get
that yeah I I will say as somebody who
does political communications for a
living I wish this weren't the way that
things go but it is shockingly common
for the subject of a profile or an
interview to be given an opportunity to
read it and like suggest amendments or
raise objections before the george w
bush sighs w bush ask you to new it you
know he gave me everything he gave you
full access and just said go ahead
in fact he hasn't read it yet has he put
it really is that true come on no I see
put it I know how it turns out uh
no no it's he lived life but he trusted
you because your feet is a fair arbiter
Aspen that's mental I hope so you did
Jefferson and you weren't mean to him
well yeah uh you know Jack T Jefferson
didn't object Hamilton did oh god that's
you what a great joke for history major
all right thank you everybody we gotta
go I appreciate you being here folks